a fortune is missing from a regional  bank police are calling it one of the  largest cash heists ever on American  soil the estimated hall 17 million  dollars authorities have no leads as to  the identity of these criminal  masterminds let's do it this roblem is  Fargo oh that bullet just went straight  between your cheeks yeah feels like it  just grazed my biscuits right there  betwixt them dear merciful Lord it's me  david see praying forgive me for  stealing all this loot he's praying I  promise I'm gonna do something noble  with it Lock opening a teen camp for  at-risk horses  so Oh y'all women kill not in front of  oh he's one of them no dance break this  hold on i'm out here don't worry about  fine Lord us a cheap door you gotta give  me a freak out next time place your  boobies sometimes the only way out it's  true  you